the phrase life imitates art is one that
gets thrown around often in the united
states however in places like north and
south korea this saying is often a
frightening reality and it doesn't get
any less frightening when you take into
account the fact that the south korean
art that has been making waves lately
has been very very grim take squid game
for example when you take away all the
violence and the bright colours
netflix's popular survival drama is
essentially a grim social commentary
about the bottom ladder of the social
rung and the way they have to suffer at
the hands of people who have more power
than they do according to a disturbing
november 23rd news report from radio
free asia another version of this
chilling story recently became reality
when a man was sentenced to death
because of squid game sometime recently
a high school student from north korea
was caught buying a copy of squid game
that had been smuggled as rfa describes
it into the hermit kingdom on a usb
flash drive the student then proceeded
to watch the show quote with one of his
best friends in class according to rfa
sources the sources said the friend told
several other students who became
interested and they shared the flash
drive with them they were caught by the
sensors in 109 sang-mu who had received
a tip-off this reportedly led to the
student's arrest as well as the capture
of the smuggler who originally sold
netflix's survival game series to them
what's happened next might as well have
been an episode of the show at its
bleakest the person who sold the copy of
squid game was sentenced to death by
firing squad after authorities
discovered that he brought the netflix
series into the country from china the
students also received harsh punishments
ranging from years of hard labor to life
imprisonment reportedly the school's
principal and two faculty members were
also removed from their positions for
allowing this to happen rfa source said
it is certain that they will be sent to
toil in coal mines or exiled to rural
parts of the country so other school
teachers are all worrying that it could
happen to them too if one of their
students is also caught up in the
investigation all this was done in
accordance with the new elimination of
reactionary thought and culture law
which carries a maximum penalty of death
for anyone caught quote watching keeping
or distributing media from capitalist
countries particularly from south korea
and the us rfa reports sources indicate
that the show's dystopian world in which
people compete for a giant cash prize
and face elimination by death resonates
with north koreans who have risky
occupations and insecure positions
meanwhile north korea has cast similar
blame on its southern neighbour with one
report from a propaganda site in october
2021 describing squid game as a brutal
reflection of south korean society
according to nbc many south koreans
actually do feel like squid game
accurately portrays the wealth
inequality they experience just to not
on the level that north korea says
security analyst jung dunn explained it
dealt with such familiar stories of
death ridden people you come across in
real life the story stems from a deeply
rooted perception of how society looks
at failure especially individual
financial failure
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]